there are nicer ways to gain views at
least play a stupid game or some there
is if you're running out of ideas just
play a game jump posting boring to get
like this start posting good stuff wait
a new staff like you shut up cocky or
don't the guys just stop posting or
instead please stop making and play a
game dude just played a video game
pieces again
shut up the race then I'm not playing
any games
it's because there's no such thing
that's a good game
[Music]
wait a minute
this game came out literally on the same
date as fallout Fallout 3 I think so
pretty much everyone ignored it it was
also at a time where this type of games
were oversaturated but now Jesus Christ
himself came down from the sky and said
hey you know what this game you can have
it on PC and now we're playing it what a
lot of people actually don't know is
that this game is that a mod or an older
game minecraft made by not back in 2011
this is just a texture pack really and I
think if you pay close attention you can
you can feed it in the gameplay
a lot of people also don't realize this
game is just like a search I [ __ ] mad
at myself with the joke you on your
monitor looking good
the scenery is a little bland oh then
it's not a copy of solid evening so no
there's a common misconception it's
actually a copy of exam from minecraft
you know that generic minecraft
character that's who is taken from right
here we go
actual gameplay we already get through
it like this so the beauty of vanquish
is a sliding option with the slowing
down er it's sexy as [ __ ] you just got a
slide out and watch out for carpet rain
[ __ ]
this is how I was sent that's what I'm
talking about
oh yeah Earl yeah man okay
Ladon
[ __ ] yeah this game is badass what is
even happening
although it's made lobsters oh hell yeah
face finally a sign fiction I can get
behind
alright time to slide babe ick yeah boy
Oh God oh [ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ] brogard I'm
sorry 9 shoot and top it's got a brand
new bag yeah boy
that's what I'm [ __ ] talking about I
love it's so impressing when they
impressive what they can do with the new
Minecraft the modding community really
has done a great job well here's the
real question
can we slide up there oh my god
lighting is finally a good game I've
waited so long thank you and he's Maddon
keeps letting ya boy now that's what I'm
talking about
yes minecraft is the best game game of
the year burns I need some backup
I like that agreement firing arrows you
two escorts Sam everyone else provide
cover ironically I should be called
burns for all the carpet burns I'm
getting I think I'm gonna need a bigger
gun
hell yes Anika oh my god it's not a
giant enemy crab so here's this giant
enemy crab oh my god it's not our
underwear hey where did you go to
military I don't worry about it just a
break then I just have a breakdown place
there you go
stupid Russian oh my god I take it back
I'm sorry I'm sorry
Kate ultimate breakdown not everything
can hit them oh my [ __ ] god
Megatron what are you doing here auntie
G that's correct I think what a lot of
people don't realize is that this game
is an actual representation of when
Trump is done with its presidency and
I'm okay with that
whoa what's happening [ __ ] it Nick
[ __ ] with that how do I do that again
got'em hell yeah
yeah boy yeah keep dancing Wow
that's what I'm [ __ ] talking about
hell yeah man I was [ __ ] awesome yeah
slide it into your damn don't worry
about it don't worry about modern this
game is just like Gears of War I mean
Joe dokdo it is a nipple electrifying
tonight should I stop wearing you know I
take that sucked or even actually picked
my back rub
ha ha ha ha ha things on eBay hey make
it reference eBay
what the [ __ ] oh man
hell yeah anyone understand what is
happening let me know wait I finish the
mission i legit died what the [ __ ] I
gotta say this game is [ __ ] glorious
to play on PC I can finally see Fanta
but in HD this is what I've been waiting
it's not right Santa's rookie big shut
the [ __ ] up [ __ ] back the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] cute was it
[ __ ] yeah play my favorite just a song
for them can't stop dancing
[Music]
it's walling it's Molly on steroids what
the [ __ ] happened additional footage of
when me and my tía
ah
well keep them know how I meant to do
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry but
it Oh dick thing yeah
[Music]
Oh see
today my tempo
oh it's fixed in time
well well well clap it up everyone for
Vanquish sponsored sponsored video I if
you guys enjoyed that's a little preview
of vanquish I think it's a really fun
action tap game of you you're into that
[ __ ] check it out and as always
sister-sister fist how to treat carpet
burns wash your hands then clean the
wound with warm water a soft cloth and
antibacterial soap disinfect the wound
with hydrogen peroxide to apply some
yeah baby Jesus